let's just bring you a bit of breaking
news though right now because two
teenagers have been sentenced to life in
prison and Leeds Crown Court for the
murder of a 15 year old boy in
Huddersfield last September a Kerry
McLean died from a single stab wound
after he was attacked on his way home
from school in March the court heard the
two teenagers you can't be named for
legal reasons a plan carried out a
planned attack and found them both
guilty of kairi's murder so that's two
teenagers who've been jailed for life at
Leeds Crown Court
and of course we'll have more
developments from the court a little bit
later on this afternoon
so just remind you of the breaking news
just in the last few minutes two
teenagers have been jailed for life at
Leeds Crown Court for the murder of 15
year old Kerry McLean and a knife attack
this is as he walked home from a
Huddersfield school and ordered to serve
minimum terms of 16 and 18 years